I want to share with you a very
effective if not the best remedy for
bloating which just happens to be also
the most effective
detoxifier in the world so this remedy
not only helps you with bloating but gas
belching feeling nauseous
diarrhea headaches food poisoning
stomach acidity problems detox reaction
after trying something new like a lot of
times people will do some herbal remedy
or detox and they feel sick so this is a
great remedy for that also it works for
bad breath and the remedy is called
activated charcoal now I'm not talking
about the charcoal that you use in your
grill outside okay don't take that I'm
talking about
a different type of charcoal that you
can get as a remedy in the health food
store but the remedy charcoal has been
used for a very very long time in fact
there's one reference that I will put
down below of someone using it in 234 BC
charcoal has a long history of helping
certain farm animals so if an animal
like a cow had some type of digestive
distress from an infection they use
charcoal charcoal has also been found to
increase milk production probably
because it's influenced on helping
balance the pathogens from the friendly
bacteria I mean if you think about it if
you have a water filter in your house
you have charcoal in there right it has
one layer or it might be the whole
filter what is that charcoal doing well
that's what I want to talk about so here
we have a sponge
and here we have a magnet okay now
charcoal works not by absorbing
something it works by adsorption okay
adsorption if I can pull this magnet out
it's really strong
you can see that it worked by binding to
something and it helps remove this
particle and that could be some poison
toxin protein it could be a gas it could
be some type of waste but it's also a
good thing if you're being poisoned from
I mean if you have this reaction from a
medication so let's say for example
you're taking several medications at
once and you feel toxic you can take
charcoal to actually make you feel a lot
better I mean I'm being kind of funny
with medications but they are kind of
poisons and less concentrated amounts I
mean if you think about it the third
leading cause of death behind heart
disease and cancer is iotrogenic
diseases that is death caused by
physician errors now it could be
surgeries but 30 percent of that
category
is medication errors charcoal is
interesting because it has all these
little crevices and cracks which means
it has a very very very large surface
area like one cubic centimeter of
charcoal has the surface area if you
unfold it to a thousand square meters
that is a crazy large surface area so
charcoal has this electrostatic kind of
a magnetic property to bind with
different things so when you take it it
could diminish toxins and also gases and
all sorts of things that are making you
feel not good so how much do you take
well I would just read what it says in
the back the label and follow those
directions depending on what type of
charcoal you get now since we're on the
topic of a remedy realize that just
charcoal is only treating this symptom
but it's a natural way of treating the
symptom there's usually something else
causing your bloating your gas your
nauseous feeling your headaches cetera
and I created a really good video on
this topic that got millions of views
relating to the digestive system and
bloating and if you haven't seen this
video it would be a very important video
to watch check it out right here